[Musique]
tous les agriculteurs vous le diront
chaque saison vient avec son lot
d'imprévu le printemps mal député dans
notre coin on a eu de la grosse pluie
puis depuis que normalement on
aura vu car c'est le Michou cultive la
pomme de terre sur 1400 ans
passés il y a les aléas de la météo et
la hausse du coût du carburant mais un
autre élément s'ajoute au casse-tête le
prix des engrais ça comme comme allure
[Musique]
pandémie et perturbation dans les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
ralentissement de la production causée
par la guerre en Ukraine et sanctions du
Canada contre la Russie la facture
d'engrais de Marcel Michaud a doublé
cette année
de 35% sur tous les produits en
provenance de Russie y compris les
engrais azotés avant les positions des
tarifs 85 à 90% des engrais utilisés
dans l'est du Canada provenait de la
Russie le choc est brutal incertitude
inquiétude je vous dirais ça décrit
vraiment la situation actuelle que
vivent les agriculteurs l'Union des
producteurs agricoles réclament la levée
des tarifs moi je pense que le
gouvernement canadien fait fausse route
une décision qui qui va à taxer les
engrais c'est taxer la nourriture le
Canada est le seul pays du G7 imposé des
tarifs sur les engrais en provenance de
la Russie oui à vescast même le
secrétaire général de l'ONU décourage
les barrières tarifaires sur les engrais
russes pour éviter d’empirer la crise
alimentaire dans le monde pourtant le
gouvernement Trudeau maintient la ligne
dure tous les Canadiens sont pour une
régime des fortes sanctions contre la
Russie
tous les ministres autour de la table du
cabinet ne sont pas d'accord avec les
tarifs sur les engrais russes mais la
ministre des Finances reste ferme le
Premier ministre n'exclut pas d'aider
les agriculteurs les coûts pour nos
agriculteurs à travers le pays ont
augmenté
on préparation pour la prochaine saison
l'industrie doit trouver des solutions
de rechange et vite la plus importante
coopérative agricole au Canada peut se
tourner vers l'Ouest canadien pour
certains engrais comme la potasse mais
ce n'est pas suffisant pour combler tous
les besoins on continue de mettre
l'accent sur l'approvisionnement de ces
autres pays soit l'Egypte de l'Algérie
il s'attend à une nouvelle augmentation
des prix de 25 à 50% l'année prochaine
pour certains produits le Canada s'en
prend à la mauvaise cible selon lui
est-ce que ça impacte sur les
producteurs russes pas du tout seulement
les producteurs agricoles ici dans l'Est
Canada Marcel Michaud n'est pas contre
les sanctions mais ce sont des avantagés
face aux cultivateurs américains qui
n'ont aucun tarif à payer le problème je
veux dire moi ça me dérange pas de payer
le même prix le pays cher mon engrais
mais si ma compétition paye le même prix
il tente lui aussi de s'adapter de
trouver des variétés de pommes de terre
qui nécessitent moins d'engrais on
cherche les variétés qui sont plus sorti
le pour
mais le processus décès et erreur
écouteux et peut prendre des années de
crise en crise le poids sur les épaules
des agriculteurs devient lourd à porter
[Musique]
l'horizon c'est assombri les pression
que peu importe ses efforts et la
qualité de sa terre le fruit de son
travail lui échappe ici Louis Blou un
Radio-Canada s'attendait au
Nouveau-Brunswick